ein dorf in brandenburg in der gegend um
faire berlin baut carsten kirchhoff in
dritter generation dächer der
dachdeckermeister hat die korona
pandemie bislang gut überstanden doch
ausgerechnet jetzt wo die instanzen
sinken wächst der kirche auf der frust
das holz für die dächer ist plötzlich
mangelware er muss kräftig draufzahlen
seit januar etwa drei bis viermal so
viel dass es für uns gigantisch also ich
habe angebote die einfach dermaßen preis
sich aus dem anzug springen das selbst
mehr als handwerker jubel wird und ich
habe drei mal nachrechnen ob stimmt
haben sie so was schon mal erlebt also
in meiner zeit noch nicht und ich bin
seit 19 74 mit dabei muss ehrlich sagen
wir haben höhen und tiefen erlebt aber
so was in der art noch nicht
nicht nur holz auch andere bau und
rohstoffe sind deutlich im preis
gestiegen betonstahl plus 30 prozent zum
vorjahr kunststoffe bis zu 23 prozent
mehr und superbenzin plus 25 prozent
für carsten kirchhoff ein echtes problem
die verträge mit den bauherren sind
schon seit monaten geschlossen
die ausufernden kosten kann er nicht
weitergeben eigentlich käme jetzt
arbeiten um zu arbeiten von gewinnen und
dergleichen sprechen wir hier nicht mehr
also hoffnungslosigkeit will ich noch
nicht sagen aber es ist eine frust als
man hat irgendwo in gewisser weise die
nase voll
die wirtschaft erholt sich nach dem chor
ohne einbruch überraschend schnell
auch das ist ein grund dafür dass die
inflation zurück gekehrt ist auf den
höchsten stand seit zehn jahren
die preise liegen im mai nach
vorläufigen zahlen des statistischen
bundesamtes um 2,5 prozent höher als im
feuer
die gestiegenen preise spüren nicht nur
handwerker und häuslebauer duisburg
stadtteil hochfeld ein wichtiger
anlaufpunkt hier vor ort die duisburger
tafel
sie versorgt aktuell rund 800 menschen
wöchentlich mit essen
das sind jetzt tatsächlich im
allergrößten fall frauen die dann hier
her kommen meistens wird dummerweise
dann auch mit kleinen kindern oder mit
schulpflichtigen kindern die dann
tatsächlich auch hier sitzen und weinen
und sagen ich das hätte ich nie gedacht
ich bin immer mit mir mit dem leben klar
gekommen mit meinem einkommen
klargekommen jetzt steigen die preise
vor allem bei lebensmitteln eier plus
elf prozent im vergleich zum vorjahr
gemüse + 7 prozent obst + 2% ich mir
angucke obst gemüse weil man ja nur
wirklich auch brauche ich ja wirklich
keine luxus dinge sind wenn ich dann für
den lebensmitteleinkauf wie 5 euro 10
euro mehr ausgeben muss dann und auf
hartz iv angewiesen bin
dann schlägt das zu buche typischerweise
ist es so dass arme menschen sich
schlechter vor der inflation schützen
können deren einkommen wird sofort
angegriffen durch den preisauftrieb
diejenigen die beispielsweise von
staatlichen transfers abhängig sind oder
niedriger löhne beziehen
allein durch die korona pandemie sind in
duisburg noch einmal etwa 100 menschen
neu zur tafel gekommen arm und reich
fallen immer mehr auseinander
eine entwicklung die schon weit vor
corinna begonnen hat das zeigt der
aktuelle armutsbericht der
bundesregierung
danach ist seit mitte der 80er jahre der
anteil armer menschen von vier prozent
auf elf gestiegen
bei den reichen ähnlich waren es
ebenfalls vier prozent sind es
inzwischen 9,1 durch hohe reicher und
reicher und die armen wurden mehr und
mehr das heißt im klartext wir haben es
zugelassen dass diese gesellschaft sich
tief gespalten hat und wenn dann auf die
situation eine pandemie trifft dann
droht eine gesellschaft auseinander zu
brechen
in duisburg müssen spiel kowski und
seine kollegen des nach niedersachsen
fahren um ausreichend lebensmittel
einzusammeln
der bedarf wächst in der pandemie stetig
trotz staatsausgaben in rekordhöhe
bund und länder geben 500 milliarden
euro zur bewältigung der korona krise
aus hinzu kommen noch einmal 600
milliarden euro staatsgarantien für
unternehmen geld das nur zu einem
bruchteil bei armen menschen ankommt wir
werden schon während zwar kam die frage
auf den tisch bekommt zahlt das
eigentlich alles was hier an hilfen
geleistet wurden sollen diese
milliardenbeträge die als schulden sich
angehäuft haben soll die abgebaut werden
sony weitergetragen werden wir steuern
auf einen da sollten uns nichts
vormachen
ein wirklich brutalen verteilungskampf
in dieser gesellschaft zu und der kampf
um steuern rauf oder runter der wirt den
bundestags wahlkampf prägen
spitzenpolitiker positionieren sich
die steuererhöhungen das wird es mit uns
freien demokraten nicht geben das mit
olaf scholz als bundeskanzler die
vermögenssteuer sicher wieder eingeführt
wird
das werde ich mit allem was mir
gesetzgeberisch mögliche zu tun das ist
der reine klassenkampf dass die
neidsteuer die der finanzminister
braucht wenn er gleichzeitig behauptet
es wäre geld genug da aber all
diejenigen die sagen wir wollen nicht
mehr steuern reden die müssen dann schon
sagen wo das geld geben für die
daseinsvorsorge und den sozialen
zusammenhalt in zukunft hergerissen
miete strom bezahlen viele menschen die
zur tafel in duisburg gehen sind
angewiesen auf hilfe vom staat
die sozialen sicherungssysteme durch
krone unter druck in der pandemie konnte
man die defizite laufen lassen da war
die frage des ausgeglichenen
staatshaushaltes nicht relevant aber
nach der pandemie werden die fragen
jetzt umso drängender
auch wer keine hilfe braucht vom staat
muss mit steigenden preisen leben
carsten kirchhoff sorgt sich vor allem
ob er in den nächsten monaten genug
aufträge bekommt um material löhne und
steuern zu bezahlen